أه العقيد لايتون أه أول كل
هذه الضربات أه تأتي بعد ما
رأيناه كان سلسلة من أه الهجمات على
مصالحنا في المنطقة والتي بدت
منسقة إلى حد كبير ما هي الرسالة التي
ترسلها الولايات المتحدة
هنا حسنًا، آبي الرسالة هي
لا تفعل ذلك  افعل هذا لا تهاجمنا، كان هناك
12 هجومًا على قواعد في العراق
وأربعة هجمات أعتقد أنها في سوريا، لذا فإن
هذه الأنواع من الهجمات هي التي تعرضنا
نحن الأفراد للخطر ومن سخرية القدر
أنها قواعد تم استخدامها أه
لمحاربة داعش والتي  من مصلحة إيران أيضًا
محاربة داعش، فقد كانوا في
الأساس شبه حلفاء معنا
بطريقة غريبة جدًا ضد داعش، وهذا
شيء تعلم أنه لا ينبغي لهم أن
يفعلوه بنا في هذه المرحلة بالذات
ولكن بالطبع لديهم مهمة أكبر
في  على الجانب الإيراني، فهم
يدعمون حماس، ونعم، كانت هذه الهجمات
منسقة بالتأكيد. وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنها شنت
غارات جوية على منشآت في
شرق سوريا مرتبطة بإيران،
ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كانت هناك أي
إصابات، وجاءت الضربات بعد سلسلة
من الهجمات.  على القوات الأمريكية في المنطقة
التي تقول واشنطن إن طاغية متورط فيها،
CNN أو ليبرمان لديه
تفاصيل لدينا، نفذت الولايات المتحدة غارات جوية
في شرق سوريا ضد منشأتين
يستخدمهما الحرس الثوري الإسلامي الإيراني
والجماعات التابعة له في
سلسلة من الهجمات التي رأيناها  على
مدار الأسبوع ونصف الأسبوع الماضيين أو نحو ذلك
ضد القوات الأمريكية في العراق وسوريا،
قال البنتاغون إن طائرتين مقاتلتين من طراز F-16 تستخدمان
ذخائر موجهة بدقة لاستهداف
هذه المنشآت، وهي منشأة لتخزين الذخيرة
ومنشأة لتخزين الأسلحة، ويقول
المسؤولون الرسميون إن هذه المنشآت
تم استخدامنا ومساعدتنا في هذه السلسلة من
الهجمات التي شهدناها منذ 17 أكتوبر،
يقول البنتاغون إننا شهدنا 19 هجومًا
وهجمات بطائرات بدون طيار وهجمات صاروخية
ضد القوات الأمريكية في هذه البلدان مما
أدى إلى إصابة أكثر من 20 إصابة طفيفة
ومقاول مدني أمريكي واحد
قُتل نتيجة إنذار كاذب
بسبب الاعتقاد بوقوع هجوم آخر من
هذه الهجمات نظرًا للوضع الذي شعرت فيه الولايات المتحدة
أنه يتعين عليها الرد، لكن الولايات المتحدة ووزير
الدفاع لويد أوستن كانا
واضحين جدًا في وصف هذا التحذير
ووصف هذه الهجمات بأنها دفاع عن النفس.  الضربات
التي كانت موجهة بشكل ضيق لحماية
القوات الأمريكية ولكن أيضًا لإرسال رسالة مفادها
أنه سيكون هناك المزيد من الضربات إذا
استمرت الهجمات على القوات الأمريكية، كل ذلك جزء
من بيان أوستن هنا الذي
ينسب ذلك أولاً إلى إيران ويعلق
ذلك على إيران، حيث تريد إيران إخفاء ذلك.  يدها
وننكر دورها في هذه الهجمات
ضد قواتنا، ولن نسمح لها بذلك
إذا استمرت هجمات وكلاء إيران ضد
القوات الأمريكية، ولن نتردد في
اتخاذ المزيد من الإجراءات اللازمة
لحماية شعبنا، ومن ثم كان المقصود من هذه
الضربات المصممة بشكل ضيق
والدفاع عن النفس  فقط
لحمايتنا والدفاع عنا نحن العاملين في العراق
وسوريا سبق أن رأينا أمريكا
تعزز تواجد قواتها أه في
المنطقة بسبب القلق من التصعيد
من جانب وكلاء إيران
وهم حزب الله في لبنان وكذلك
هؤلاء الوكلاء الإيرانيين  في العراق وسوريا،
تنشر الولايات المتحدة وهي في طور
نشر 900 جندي في المنطقة،
بما في ذلك بطارية ثاد للدفاع الجوي
وأنظمة الدفاع الجوي باتريوت، وهذا
علاوة على كل ما رأيناه بالفعل
تحرك الولايات المتحدة إلى المنطقة
مجموعتين هجوميتين من حاملات الطائرات  مجموعة برمائية جاهزة
كلها بمثابة تحذير لإيران للبقاء خارج
هذه المعركة السؤال الآن بالطبع
هل هذه الضربات الجوية وهذه الأهداف
على المنشآت التي تستخدمها قوات الحرس الثوري الإيراني والجماعات
التابعة لها قد فهمت
الرسالة وتمت استعادة الردع
أم لا؟  هذا هو استمرار الولايات المتحدة في محاولتها
جاهدة للتأكد من عدم انتشار الصراع في غزة
إلى المنطقة الأوسع، حتى
عندما رأينا احتجاجات مناهضة لنا ومعادية لإسرائيل
في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط أو في
شبكة سي إن إن الليبرالية في البنتاغون.